today's topic
is that modern women don't care about
beauty standards that's that's my
premise today so I my first question is
what are beauty standards
and then start here go around then
second row go ahead
um for me I think you know due to the
nature of my job through singing you
know I perform a lot you know in the
public eye so I think beauty is
important uh in a way that you need to
be confident enough for people to you
know to see your talent eventually I
mean there are different beauty
standards I'm From Italy so as you
probably can imagine
um maybe the beauty standards over there
are just a little bit different who's
someone that is the Italian beauty
standard is there like a celebrity yeah
celebrities or you know people on teams
no just like someone you could think of
um Monica Bellucci Monica could we put
her on the screen I just want to see
what she looks like yeah
okay it's an actress I'm gonna I'm gonna
look it up here just while he's doing it
so I can see is she tall short she told
um Brown uh hair okay you know the
typical Mediterranean oh yeah yeah I
don't know if you considered it as a
beautiful I think she's beautiful
um but
um I think for I would lie if I would
say like no beauty doesn't matter at all
I mean it's that's I think it's a lie to
me personally speaking but at the same
time I wouldn't generalize you know for
different people beauty can be different
I for me for example I try like to look
nice without always being so up there
like showing up like your body all the
time so that can be beautiful because
you can you know let men guess what is
behind you yeah you're a very I like
your outfit a lot it's
do you think that um British women um
have you been to America too I'm just
curious yes yes what would you say
um who is more put together usually when
they go out American women British women
or Italian women
yes because you know we are this is why
you know I say from the beginning I come
from a country where like you know being
nice and looking nice is quite important
but at the same time I feel like my
beauty standards are not necessarily
what the modern women they want to you
know say like oh yes let's put you know
boobs out everything out and that's
beautiful sexy and provocative I kind of
like like to people guess more what's
behind you know the surface would you
say in Italy
um
that
that like beauty standards are higher
there or lower
yes yes definitely like from TV you know
anything you know you can see if you're
not in a certain type of body shape
sometimes can be I mean it's changing
it's changing but I feel like there is
still quite predominant that like and
what would you say about
um like promiscuous clothes is that more
I'm just curious because we don't always
get people from Italy on the show
um so would you say that that's more
frowned upon in Italy or
um or is it more open there it's a
warmer I think the thing is you know
with the younger Generations is really
changing because they're quite more into
this Western World you know they're
bombarded with social media and images
and everyone is trying to impress
everyone so it's changing a little bit
but I would say and you know people like
myself or you know other friends or
acquaintances you know we like to think
that there are also part of women that
still like to not impress just you know
by I'm gonna be naked tonight and I'm
gonna show you know how sexy I am there
is sexiness isn't being absolutely fully
covered I believe so okay
um so what do you think
um to me it's I feel like it's within to
be honest with you but I'm also half
asian so
in the vision Community beauty is being
revealing and like in the when the
you're sorry say that again Paul fascia
and say Barbados okay
um so we usually are quite you know
revealing and nails done hair makeup
sort of thing
um but yeah as I said Beauty to me is is
within okay and you can't tell if one
girl is more attractive than the other
it all looks the same
um
but then that goes by preference I can
say well this person that's really good
and but then again this yeah goes by its
preference like I might think this
person doesn't look so good
um where to others someone else they
might look really good you don't think
there's General Beauty at all like you
think it's different for every person or
do you think that in general we can kind
of tell who's the most attractive and
who's the least attractive
to society yeah who's Society
to also science say yeah but when you
say Society like who who is society
um well people in the UK okay so you
would say that people can tell who's
more attractive and less attractive
um because you're like that's another
thing like when you say Society it's
people right yeah it's people it's
people in the UK but I think it's
different all over as I said like in
Barbados they would say Rihanna is what
you call
um you know Beauty
um attraction she's you know she's she's
very pretty she'd say that in America
too yeah
yeah everywhere come on
yeah but you know like over here I do is
she not beautiful somewhere
where is Rihanna not hot that's true
you know like I feel like there's like
preferences like some people like might
think one celebrity's hotter than the
other but they're all hot yeah you know
unless you're blind you can tell so
that's why I just never understand what
people say that like if I look I if I
look at Beyonce I don't think she's in
comparison to
um you know to Rihanna I think Beyond is
more beautiful to me than Beyonce so
I mean just
depends when I don't know because
Beyonce is a bit older isn't she yeah
but it doesn't matter about that I think
my preference is Rihanna over Beyonce
okay what do you think what are beauty
standards like she said it's within you
I'm very big on that I don't know
even if Beyonce came in you might say
Rihanna's hotter but Beyonce's still hot
nobody can deny that Beyonce's High yeah
yeah she's pretty but like everyone has
their own preferences so who you might
think's good looking I might think he's
definitely not what about men
do you think men look at women and say
the same thing the beauty comes from
within
um
[Music]
but I'm all like the ones that have been
hurt maybe they start looking at beauty
within maybe the ones that have been
hurt
that's when you start hearing what is it
what's the saying they say beyond the
eyes or something like that they say
right yeah then you start hearing that
but you would say in general men do look
at Beauty
to an extent I definitely
sometimes don't think men look at
anything but oh you know just
what they can have okay so um when we
talk about beauty standards it's all
about to you it's all about what comes
from within yeah nothing physical my
background's Indian so I've actually
picked up her she's Beijing I'm Indian
and we pretty much cover ourselves
back home
what does that have to do with the
beauty so that comes within because
we're not here we're quite covered up to
be fair so we look at Beauty like they
very well I'm from a village so oh yeah
yeah so they don't wear makeup they they
just literally they my mum's always said
this to me what part of India are you
from Punjab where is that that's like in
a border right next to Pakistan so it's
closer to Pakistan side so I miss I
would say South India okay because I
went to um Abu Dhabi or not sorry not
Abu Dhabi that's right sorry sorry
Hyderabad Hyderabad where's that it's in
India yeah India's really big I think
it's South I think I don't know it was a
long time ago I was I I barely can
remember the name obviously
it's a bit different because we're from
Village and we just like we
women always do their hair but they're
very rarely wear makeup they're very
rarely wear
but yeah anything really they just the
guys don't have to have their head on so
that's where my grandparents are from so
when I look at that and I'm like B is
from within
so that's what I mean when I say that uh
what do you think beauty standards
um I mean I kind of have to disagree
with the ladies to my left because I
feel like it's evident
um I feel like everybody knows who like
a beautiful person is I feel like if a
woman walks in the room you'll know that
a woman will be classified as beautiful
if she has her nails done her hair's
done her eyelashes her eyebrows
everything is straight everything is put
together
um I feel like if another woman was to
walk in and she doesn't have that I
won't I don't feel like people won't say
she's beautiful I just feel like people
will be more attracted and will look
um to the woman who has everything done
first initially to get what I mean so I
feel like
um and to answer your question about men
I feel like men that's the first thing
they look at Beauty before they look at
anything else as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible